mhhhm
Bonjour à tous !
Bonjour à tous ! Cette semaine on est à Tokyo, la ville de toutes les extravagances !
Et comme on dit ici, Irassahaimase ! (= Bienvenue !)
Oh, y'a Dark Vador sur la piste!
Donc l'hôtesse de l'air, viens quand même de me demander, si j'étais japonais.
Ca fait maintenant 19 heures qu'on vole.
Je.. Je pas forcement fatigué mais...
Oula ! Merde !
On prend un ticket de métro ? Alors umh..
Tu veux pas qu'on y aille a pied plutôt?
La carte pingouin !
Alors c'est bien connu, à Paris, les parisiens font la gueule dans le métro.
Mais au japon ça na rien avoir, ils font la gueule, en japonais!
Alors la on est, on est, on est perdus...
Et mais mec, ça c'est le métro hein, l'arcade c'est la bas.
Bon j'ai un peut triché, haha, félicitations !
Je crois que jai trouvé le plus wtf que wtf, un jeux video de jetage de table.
Le principe c'est que t'es un père de famille et il s'énerve parce que ces enfants téléphonent à table,
alors il balance la table dans la pièce.
Yes ! J'ai fais chialer mes gosses ! 18 points !
Et non ! Ceci n'est pas une corde à rideaux,  mais bel et bien la queue d'un chat
Nous sommes dans un bar à chat dans le coeur de Tokyo
ou on peut venir prendre une petite collation et caresser ses animaux.
On a rencontré le cousin japonais de Sergie, alors il s'appelle Bato, comme un bateau, mais euh, sauf que c'est son prénom.
Cet animal ne possède pas de visage.
Chat caméléon !
Le chat en prison !
"moi je ne m'amuse pas vraiment!"
Konichiwa !
¿ Comó te llamas ?
Oh il est trop mignon !
Il y a quand même pas mal de chirurgiens dans la ville, t'as vu?
Voila je suis béni, enfin je sens surtout le barbecue en fait.
Ils se sont un peu inspirés de kung-fu panda pour le décors
Je vais leur dire.
Alors ta mis combien? 5000 yens. 5000 yens ?! ouais, ça fait combien?
50 euros. 50 euros? J'ai mis 50 euros ?? (Juste 38 € en fait)
Ah ça m'a donné des forces, le temple shibwayu..shjibe..Je sais plus..(Le temple Sensoji )
Les mecs ils ont des ps3, et ils ont ça comme chaussures quoi.
hop la !
Mon premier sushi japonais.
Ceux qui disent que dans les sushi, l'avocat et le crabe, c'est des sushi occidentalisé, américains
prennez-vous ça dans la face!
Un vrai sushi du japon qui a de l'avocat et du crabe !
Alors pour le thé ici,
il y a une petite boite avec une sorte de poudre.
Tu la mets comme ça.
Par contre je ne sais pas combien de doses..
On va dire euh.. 3 doses.
De l'eau chaude,
tu mélanges évidemment,
J'en ai mis trop en fait.
Oh c'est dégueulasse !
Haha ! On dirait un masque pour la peau sous forme liquide !
Je savais pas mais il cache du wasabi entre le poisson et le riz.
J'ai pris une grosse bouchée et...
ça arrache !
mais je suis un homme. (Cette virilité !)
Baseball sur les toits de Tokyo, c'est fait!
Matte ce style!
Ca c'est très très facile, ça veut dire bicycle donc en anglais c'est vélo, donc une gare à vélo en fait.
Bon voila c'est des petits mots comme ça que je connais. C'est la culture G quoi.
Merci à tous d'avoir passer une semaine de folie ici à Tokyo,
la semaine prochaine on part à Hawaii pour le soleil, les palmiers et les filles en fleurs !
Alors comme on dit ici, Domo Arigato (= Merci beaucoup !) et Sayonara ! (=Aurevoir !)